on regarde la première page de
couverture je dis rapidement le contenu
je vais continuer à lire tout en parlant
moi je ferme souvent les yeux je suis
capable de lire un livre de d'environ
300 pages en 10 15 minutes avec une très
bonne compréhension
[Musique]
la première des choses c'est que
lorsqu'on aborde un livre on se pose
toujours des questions d'abord on
regarde la première page de couverture
mais quand j'y on regarde on regarde
l'ensemble des éléments ensuite je
regarde la quatrième page de couverture
donc là quand je dis rapidement le
contenu on parle de Nina qui a 30 ans
qui est juriste oui
en faisant je sais avec moi oui après je
regarde s'il y a un sommaire puisque le
sommaire va donner un peu le le
squelette du livre ça dure en tout là
vraiment 15 20 secondes vous gardez le
livre devant vous vous posez des
questions moi je ferme souvent les yeux
parce que quand je ferme les yeux
j'imagine plus on imagine et plus
justement on va augmenter cette
créativité et savoir renforcer justement
par la suite la capacité à mémoriser et
après donc du coup je pars en lecture et
quand je pars en lecture la deuxième
conseil du coup je vais vous donner
c'est de suivre avec son doigt ou avec
un tuteur ou un stylo ou un guide visuel
bref voilà je vais lire de cette façon
là ça permet de garder en concentration
de rester focus et de pas être dérangé
par un parasite extérieur si je veux je
veux augmenter ma vitesse et je vais
continuer à lire tout en parlant tu vois
le troisième conseil que j'ai à donner
c'est ce qu'on appelle la cohérence
cardiaque donc c'est une technique de
respiration qui est très facile à faire
pour qu'elle soit bien efficace on l'a
fait trois fois par jour ça dure 5
minutes pendant cette phase là on va en
fait il y a tout un tas de choses qu'on
met en place pour la concentration dont
la en fait on construit une bulle autour
de soi et ça pour pour un athlète du
cerveau c'est hyper hyper primordial et
on le voit souvent chez les athlètes
surtout ceux qui font de la course avant
de commencer une course et pendant
plusieurs minutes ils sont dans leur
petite bulles donc nous dans la lecture
c'est pareil si je devais donner un
conseil qui permettrait de
d'améliorer surtout la mémorisation
c'est de prendre des notes parce que
quand on lit il est primordial de
prendre des notes et quand je prends je
dis on prend des notes on recopie pas
tout on prend uniquement des mots qui
sont orientés mémorisation on synthétise
à base de mots clés tout un livre on
n'est pas obligé de vraiment de lire
très très vite comme je le dis en
compétition parce que en fait on choisit
son mode de lecture en fonction de son
objectif et surtout fonction de son
support je vais pas lire un magazine
comme je vais lire un roman comme je
vais lire une doc technique comme je
vais lire un sms chaque lecture à son
objectif et on adapte aussi en fait sa
méthode en fonction de tout ça
de lire vite bon il y a tellement
bénéfices bon je vais en citer quand
même quelques-uns mais lire vite ça
permet de gagner du temps d'être plus
productif d'être mieux concentré on a
des moments où on lit par obligation vos
scolaires professionnels je vais lire
vite comme ça je le passe et je fais
autre chose après derrière qui me plaît
[Musique]